Hey Youtubers it's Charlie so the flash producers
have teased us with the idea of the multiverse
the idea of multiple timelines so what I'm
in a do is explain the history of the DC multiverse
the comic book multiverse and then explain
how the TV show might adapt that. A lot of
you have also asked if the Flash multiverse
will create a back door to connect the TV
shows with the movies and that's not the case.
Anything you see on TV will have nothing to
do with what's going on in Batman v Superman
or any the other movies. The very first version
of the comic book multiverse started out in
1940 in All-Star comics number three.  It was
actually a pretty like crossover between
characters. It was the first official meeting
of the Golden Age Justice Society of America.
Justice league didn't become a thing till
1960. The first just the society was Johnny
Thunder, the Jay Garrick Flash, Hawkman, the
Jim Corrigan Spector, Hourman, the Ma Hunkel
Red Tornado, the Wesley Dodds Sandman, Doctor
Fate, the Al Pratt Atom, and the Alan Scott
Green Lantern.  Funny fact, at the time Hawkman's
weapon was called the Hammer of Thor.  Yeah, I'm
sure Marvel's laywers really liked that Johnny
Thunder's magic thunderbolt brought them all
together and they just took turns telling
each of their most interesting stories. The
reason why they call the multiverse story
is is because prior to this the other characters
didn't exist in each other's titles. So like
the Allen scribe Green Lantern didn't reference
Batman in his comics. The first multiple first
situation didn't show up till 1959 in Wonder
Woman number 59. She gets transported to an
alternate earth and meets a woman named Tara Terruna who looks just like her.  Basically
like that earth version of Wonder Woman. What
you know as the multiverse today really started
out during the Silver Age in "The Flash of
Two Worlds".  The Barry Allen flash debuted in
showcase number four in 1956. It was part of the big
Silver Age reboot. They fridged all their Golden
Age characters and just re-imagined them in
new more interesting ways. That showcase issue
was just two Flash stories. It told the
story of how he got struck by the thunderbolt
and got superspeed, but they hadn't invented
the idea of the Speed Force yet so was just
a normal lightning bolt.  It was also the first
appearance of his costume ring and the first
time that he time traveled by going superspeed.
So everybody loves Barry Allen, all is right with
the world, but they get the idea for him to
"phase" into another Earth and he meets Jay
Garrick. This is "Flash of Two Worlds".  This was
in 1963. The way they explained it is is that
he was trying to do a party trick in Central
City and vibrated his molecules so that he
would look invisible, but instead he ends up
appearing in front of another city. That ends
up being Keystone City, which at this time
was an alternate Earth. So he meets Jay Garrick
and learns about the other Flash. Just to tie it
back to the TV show for a second, so Central
City is where the particle accelerator is
on this side of the river on the other side
of the river is Keystone City so they sit
right next to each other, but that's the TV show.
It didn't start out that way in the comics.
Keystone city used to only be on another earth.
Later that earth became Earth-Two and they
started introducing the naming convention
where you have Earth-One, Earth-Two, then you have the multiverse
with like Earth-X, Earth-S for all these
different characters. So we're still in the 1960s
right now we're a long ways away from Crisis
on Infinite Earths in the 80s. What happened
is is that the "The Flash of Two Worlds" was such a
popular story that DC decided to bring back
all of its Golden Age characters and just
put them on Earth-Two.  So now they could tell
stories with their old characters without
it complicating what was going on with their
Silver Age characters and they can always
do crossovers. The first big Flarrow type crossover
they did was later 1963 just like a couple
months after they did "Flash of Two Worlds".
They had the Silver Age justice League crossover
with the Golden Age Justice Society. That
became like a yearly thing like their yearly
version of Flarrow.  For the next 20 years after
that, DC slowly gained the rights to characters
and tried to fold them into continuity so they
started introducing the idea of Earth-S, Earth-X,
like all these different Earth's. That's
where you get to the shit storm of continuity
errors that led to Crisis on Infinite Earths,
but originally Crisis was meant to be like
a 50th anniversary story.  Marv Wolfman is the
one that that wrote Crisis on Infinite Earths,
but the idea was pitched that they would use
this event to clean up their continuity because
it'd just gotten so crazy.  Editorial was just having
way too many problems keeping track of all
their characters. So Post-Crisis, what you have
is a single earth with a single timeline and
all the survivors of Crisis on Infinite Earths, so
some of the Golden age characters survive
most of them were killed off, especially
a lot of the crazier characters.  So it was all
born out of editorial just trying to simplify
things but eventually things spun out of control
all kinds of continuity errors despite all
the trouble they'd gone through and you get
to Zero Hour. Zero Hour was like the next big
event meant to clean up a bunch of different
timelines.  It was more about multiple timelines
collapsing than multiple earths collapsing
so just a small distinction.  Everybody be sure
to give Hal Jordan a big pat on the back for
that cleanup.  The problem is, is that continuity
errors kept happening again and again and again
you get to Hypertime as a way to explain
things with multiple different timelines
You get infinite crisis which brings back
the multiverse from pre-Crisis on Infinite
Earths... already this is like spinning out
of control. It gets super complicated.
Post Flashpoint, there were 52 versions of
Earth left.  They fell like this was enough
to have some really cool crossovers and
a bunch of different versions of characters.
Enough so that it wouldn't get too complicated
but that ended up being the case anyway. So
that's where you get to the big Convergence event
right now where they're trying to collapse
a bunch of timelines, get rid of a bunch of,
stuff reboot the characters.  That's why they
keep advertising the new DC universe.  So in
the comics the multiverse is all about multiple
versions of characters sharing the same physical
space together, like talking to each other.
The TV show probably not going to go that
route. They'll probably go the alternate timeline
route.  That doesn't even begin to get into the
idea of the Positive Matter Universe and the
Antimatter Universe.  That's actually... Jeff Johns
is actually playing with that idea in the
Darkseid War title that he is writing right
now.  It's happening in Justice league, it's
part of the Justice league title.  Any way you
look at though, the comic book multiverse from
a logistical standpoint is a complete nightmare.
So that's why TV shows thus far have tried
to avoid it.  Smallville did try to do a version
of the multiverse using the mirror box. Where
you know you have like "Crime Syndicate Version"
of Clark.  A lot of you did ask too during the
Flash finale if, you know when we see the Flash
Museum and Killer Frost, if that's part of
the multiverse too.  Technically it's not. It's really
just different points in Barry's single timeline
like in his own timeline.  He wasn't seeing
different branches.  So like Killer Frost for
instance happens in the future of his own
timeline.  But what about the Jay Garrick helmet?
How do you explain that?  Is that from the future?
Is that from the past?  Like, where did it come
from?  The way I'm choosing to think about it,
at least until the Flash writers and the producers
tell us otherwise, is it that that vortex they created
is kind of like a time-space train depot that
anybody can enter if they achieve the right speed or have the right technology.  They really
haven't told us that much so I want to speculate
too much on where that Jay Garrick helmet came from,
but I know a lot of you guys are hoping that
Jon Wesley Shipp will get to be like an alternate
timeline version of the Flash, he'll be like
the Jay Garrick Flash.  They could do that, it's
a little on the nose, I'm not expecting it.  The producers did say we would see multiple
versions of the Flash.  Wally West is the only
one that they said out loud but they did show
us the Jay Garrick helmet so that's the other
Flash there.  So when they say multiple Flashes,
they could just mean "references to other Flashes"
instead of, like, actually casting actors as
them. But I do feel like when the show gets
to Wally West, it'll be an actual actor. They
will cast him and we'll see him interact with
Barry the other characters.  Really you have to remember
that the TV show's number one mission is to
do an interesting story and keep it as easy
to follow as possible.  So it's like, you know,
if you don't read comics you need to be able
to follow this time travel storyline.  That's
why I don't think they're going to get
really crazy with the comic book multiverse.
It'll be relatively simple... and will
stay in this single timeline, it's just that this giant
vortex that Barry is trying to close will allow some
stuff from alternate timelines to spill into
our timeline.  They'll use it as a storytelling
device the same way they used the particle accelerator
explosion during Season One to create all
the metahumans.  So think of it as a giant mixing
bowl across time and space, that it's probably
going to take Barry the first two episodes
to close, and I'd I do think he'll close it in
the first couple of episodes, but not before
it allows a whole bunch of other stuff to
spill into their timeline.  Right away I can
say that Tom Cavanaugh is still a series regular
so he'll come back on the show in an alternate
form.  Probably like the original Harrison Wells.
One that did not get killed by the Reverse
Flash.  Eddie coming back is a little bit harder
but they said that he would appear at least
a couple times, but only as a guest star. That
could be in flashbacks, it could be alternate
timelines, it's just that they're slowly dipping
their toe in the idea of Barry time traveling.
Because he still figuring things out he's
probably going to make some derps, and that's
probably what's going to lead to some of these
alternate timelines showing up, but for the
most part like from a story perspective most
this is going to flow from that giant vortex
in the sky.  Everybody hold their breath for
the TARDIS to come down and Rory to
stick his head out before Legends of Tomorrow.
Time travel.  Going to a big thing in Flash
Season Two.  You have to remember that Legends of
Tomorrow is a time travel based story, so
part of that is going to inform what's going
on with Vandal Savage.  Here's my big question for
you guys though:  Where do you think that that
Jay Garrick helmet came from in the Flash
Finale?  Is that from the past of Barry's own
timeline or is that from an alternate universe?
For the most part though I'm expecting the
idea of just, you know, multiple timelines where
characters make different choices leading
to different outcomes.  That being said, Caitlin
Snow, supposedly going to be turning into Killer
Frost. I think that will be "our" version of
Caitlin.  It's not going to be an alternate universe
version of Caitlin.  So, because I haven't done
a video on that character yet, what I'm probably
going to do is my next bonus video will
just be all Killer Frost so be sure to subscribe
to get that.  They haven't announced any of
the new characters yet, but if there is anybody you
want me to do a video on just let me know
in the comments.  I know a lot of you guys really want me to
do a Supergirl pilot video, so I'll probably do
that next week.  I feel like it's okay now.
Enough time is past.  While you guys wait for that to
post, you can click here to learn all about
Mirror Master in the comics and what's going
on with him in Season Two and you can click
here to learn about all my favorite games
from E3 this year.  Thank you so much for watching,
everybody, let's high five.  I'll see you
guys tomorrow!